hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game app from day 4 of the
meltwater Champions Chester finals it is
Anish giri with the white pieces versus
Magnus Crossing with black all three
games they played were absolutely
incredible and yes I'm saying there were
three of them and all three with very
decisive results and I could have shown
you uh either of those three I decided
to show you this one as it features
everyone's favorite opening the French
defense so let's dive straight into it
uh Anish has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to e for NDS going into
day four magnets and Duda are leading
the tournament both with um a perfect
score so E4 E6 Magnus goes for the
French defense D4 D5 and now Knight the
C3 we have Knight to F6 and pawn to E5
the steinits variation advancing the
pawn challenging the Knight Knight after
D7 and now Pawn to F4 we have C5
striking in the center this is all very
very standard stuff Knight F3 uh Knight
the C6 and now Bishop to E3 both of them
playing the absolute top
moves A6 and now Queen to D2 We have
found the B5 and here uh the standard
replies D capitals and C5 or Pawn to A3
uh Anish goes for Pawn to A3 and now
Queen to A5 interestingly Queen to B6 is
played um
quite a few more times than Queen to A5
uh but um last time it was played it was
in 2021 so the queen to B6 even though
it's been played more it's uh it's uh
well it's literally last year's move so
here Queen to A5 this is sort of the
improved version Bishop to E2 now going
um maybe deciding to Castle and now
Magnus goes for it pawn to B4 uh you
cannot capture as the rook and A1 is
hanging so Knight back to B1 or D1 are
the options and each goes for Knights to
D1 and Rook the B8 now we have Castles
by a niche and there is a game where B
captures an A3 was played it's a very
nice game between you and and the
dinglier and it was played some 10 years
ago in in the tournament somewhere I
believe in China but here that ended in
the draw but here we have pawned a C4 by
Magnus uh which is still not a new game
Ponte A4 and now uh here we have Bishop
to E7 there is one game where Pawn to B3
was played uh but Magnus goes to Bishop
to E7 and it is now as of move 13 then
we have a completely new game and this
is where uh well our our Interest really
begins so here Queen to E1 and each
wants to shift the queen over to the
king side to start an attack on magnus's
King uh we have B3 Magnus offers a queen
trade and now C3 Anish prevents this by
blocking the uh the queen if you trade
let's say captures captures black is
just the better here there's uh not all
that much white has to show for You're
Gonna Play C3 and then something like
Knight to B6 Bishop to D7 you're gonna
capture the A4 pawn and then you're just
gonna move your pieces Advanced the past
the a DA pawn and it's going to be a
better position for black so Anish of
course closes this C3 he wants the queen
side quotes he wants the center closed
so he can attack on the king's side
Knight the B6 by Magnus goes after the
the A4 Pawn or so you would think and
here Anish has to figure out how to go
about this position it's an incredibly
tricky position that you can I'm not
gonna ask you to pause the video and try
to figure out what to play here because
it's uh it's an incredibly complicated
position this is basically where you
decide uh how uh what turn the game will
take and you could you could either make
it a very good game for white or you
could make it a very bad game for white
so just you know enjoy the position uh
you know Savor the position if you will
uh it's just uh it's just so complicated
that I'm not even going to show you how
to play this I will show you after we
actually check out the game if some of
you are interested in that because it's
such a disgusting Engine line so here
Anish plays Pawn to F5 he wants them
open up lines in front of the black king
and it makes sense to give up a pawn to
do that so e captures an F5 and the
Magnus said in an interview after the
game that he was uh kind of scared in
this position but after Anish played F5
he thought uh either I'm gonna lose like
really quickly in a couple of moves or
I'm completely fine so he captures on F5
we have Queen to G3 now going after the
G7 pawn and the G6 defending uh both G7
and now F5 is sufficiently defended
Bishop to G5 and now Bishop to E6 by
Magnus with Bishop the F6 attacking the
rook and Magnus trades here Bishop
capture spawn captures and now Knight to
D7 as The Rook on V8 is attacked so you
want to have it sufficiently defended uh
Knight the G5 now and here we have Rook
the C8 Magnus doesn't like his Rook on
B8 so he shifts it over to C8 and now
Anish should play Queen to E3 to put
pressure on the bishop here but he
decides the cap to right away Knight
captures an E6 F capris and queen to D6
seems like it's the same idea you're
attacking E6 you're threatening F7 King
characters Queen captors Knight on D7
however there's that annoying move that
always saves you whenever you
have a bad position and that of course
is a move with the Knight back Magnus
plays Knight to f8 and this solves all
of his problems you don't have to worry
about the E6 Pawn you don't have to
worry about F7 check there's really not
all that much to worry about here so
Anish has to figure out how to continue
and it's just not easy to find the move
because there are no moves here so
Anisha wants to kind of open up the E
file he plays Bishop captures on C4 to 3
FD file for the Rooks D captures on C4
and not Knights the E3 getting the
Knight into the attack Queen to C7 now
Magnus offers a queen trade Knight
captures on C4 and now of course you
cannot capture Knight captures on D6
will uh will make a very nice Fork so
King the F7 and now Pawn to D5 again you
can't really go for this it will still
be a nice Fork the king and Rook will
get forked uh so Knight to d8 by Magnus
D captures an E6 with check Knight f-cap
present E6 and not Knight the E5 check
and Magnus has two options King that E8
loses terrible you do not want to go
King to E8 if King T8 then just F7 check
and you resign your other option is to
go King to G8 which is possible but I
have to rotate to D1
white will have some fighting chances so
after Knight to E5 check Magnus played
the strongest move and that is the
boldly capture on F6 King captures and
F6 and although the king is in a very
weird spot you don't really have a good
way to continue the attack if you go for
some like Knight G4 check you just move
the king back King to G7 and you don't
have a continuation here probably just
trading and that's pretty much it you go
for the end game and you're lost so
instead Knight the D7 check we have King
to F7 King to G7 allows Anish to grab a
draw because there's this annoying
Perpetual here Queen to H4 with check
now and or even better after Queen t7
check you can block with the Knight now
a queen to F6 check it doesn't matter
how you play this if King H6 Queen H4
check and here you will just um kind of
continue checking even if King the G8
then Queen can capture on E6 which will
again be a draw yeah so after night the
D7 check King the F7 is important not to
allow Queen D7 now comes Queen to D5
again Anish cannot trade Queens here we
have rooked the E8 we have Rook 8 to D1
bringing the final attacker into the
game and the King to G7 finally on
pinning we have G4 on each wants to open
up the f file for The Rook but not Pawn
to F4 we have Ponte A5 as now Anish was
very low on time so yeah I mean you
don't have anything to play your very
long time it's just a very sad position
we have Knight to F7 Rook after E1
attacking the Knight Here and Now Rook C
the d8 but now yeah there's really not
all that much to worry about Magnus
Anish pushes H4 uh we have F3 and it was
in this position after Magnus pushed F3
that Anil giri resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here by
playing F3 Magnus invites his own Queen
into White's camp and now Queen to G3
will be deadly Queen G3 check and then
you just Checkmate the the white king
and there's no good way to stop this
even if King F1 still Queen to G3 it's
just a terrible terrible position now of
course after F3 Anish just resigned the
game so interestingly Magnus won the
first one the second one and the third
one so he takes down a niche three to
zero which is absolutely incredible uh
and uh uh I I could have shown you
either of the three games but this one
was with the black pieces in the
frontier defense I thought you guys
would enjoy this one the most but now
let's return to that position where I
asked you
after Magnus played Knight to B6 uh what
would you play here with white well I uh
left the engine to Crunch the numbers I
took Meadow for a walk and when I
returned it had like a depth 46 or
something and the engine gives this as
the correct way to play this with a
white H4 and now of course black will
play H5 you do not want to allow white
to further advance that pawn now you
play Knights the G5 and now uh there's
not all that much for Magnus to do here
it's very interesting what happens if he
actually captures the pawn on A4 because
it is a it is a free Pawn but now you're
uh your knight can't really move and
your queen can't really move very far
away because the Knight would be hanging
and you get even though the engine gives
this as the best move for black but now
look at this queen G3 G6 and now Bishop
to F3 and now only now white prepared
everything sufficiently for the advanced
advancement of the pawn to F5 which
Anish started with but there were a few
moves maybe uh to prepare this because
now look at this let's say Bishop to D7
Ponte F5 and if G captures an F5 now
look at this spectacular move Knight to
H7
uh yes that is that is how you have to
play and that's what you you absolutely
must be able to do if you are to defeat
the French defense the French defense is
so hard to play against and if you can't
play like this uh you you will not be
able to beat it so the idea is that of
course if row captures just Queen to G8
with checks so the only move for black
to survive this is King to d8 Queen G7
King to C7 now the Rooks are nicely
defended and now Bishop to G5 and if
let's say Rook beat the G8 attacks the
queen queen captures on F7 Bishop
captures and g5h captures on G5 and now
Queen to B6 with a very nice trick uh
threatening Knight captures on E5 but
white doesn't care you can play Knight
to F6 you can also play Knights the E3
but Knight to F6 is sufficient Knight
captures on E5 now uh the Knight cannot
be captured the queen is hanging Queen
to E7 and now Knight captures on F3 Rook
captures and queen to D6 offering a
queen trade Queen to F7 and here black
is without a move it's such spectacular
stuff the problem is your rook and G8 is
hanging and also the Knight on A4 is
hanging that Knight that captured that
pawn because the the bishop cannot move
uh is hanging uh but even though
capturing the pawn was the best move uh
if you ask our good friend the engine
but it's hard to say even in the depth
45 or 46 that the engine achieved the
engine never really finds its way out of
uh you know uh crunched positions like
that where you don't have uh all that
many moves if it's a tactical position
if it's an open position the engine will
just Crush you but here it's more of a
strategic one where you know pawns are
and none of the captors are really
possible maybe uh the engine has no idea
what it's talking about who knows but
okay here the the point is if some like
rooked fade and queen characters and
these seven you just trade queens and
then the Knight on A4 will still be
hanging captures captures captures
captures and real captures here and
you're just up a full piece of course
completely winning
uh but yeah just a hypothetical line uh
like a really hypothetical line how to
go about this position so not F5 but
first to put all your pieces on optimal
squares and then push F5 you don't have
to worry about the A4 Pawn so you know
if you face the French defense if it's a
weird position consider doing something
like this might work out for you
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely played by magnets
like I said the beating Anish 3-0 is not
an easy thing and we are also going to
check out one more game and then we are
going to discuss the standings as um I
mean truly truly a spectacular
tournament is being played here uh so
yeah I once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank
ravishing reptiles YouTube Harry Barton
Mario Francis air and Carmen uh
polyphronium for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day